jouer en équilibre sur un ballon
renforcement musculaire et parcours
physique et tout cela autour d'une table
de ping pong
non vous ne rêvez pas le fid ping
tonique arrive dans les salles
créé il ya un an par la fédération
française le sud ping est un parfait
mélange de fitness et d'activités
sportives
c'est très énergique c'est sympa ouais
j'ai déjà fait le baby ping
ça aide à améliorer la précision la wii
c'est sympa moi qui fait un peu de sport
en salle c'est vrai que c'est original
ça change et on permet de faire du les
deux disciplines sont complémentaires le
tennis de table développe l'habilité les
réflexes et le tonus musculaire
principal atout du fitness
la cible de cette nouvelle discipline
est toute trouvée les femmes qui ne
représentent que 17% des joueurs de ping
pong en france quand on fait une bonne
séance on transpire bien et je pense
qu'on peut perdre mois entre 500 et 600
calories par séance ce qui est pas mal
il ya beaucoup de travail de
renforcement musculaire surtout pour le
gainage parce qu'entre le dos travaille
beaucoup au tennis de table
on se rend pas bien compte mais avoir
des bonnes lambert c'est important la
naissance du fils qui me permet aussi de
faire oublier la réputation de sport
détente du tennis de table
et quand on voit les joueurs
professionnels d'elancourt évolué et on
comprend pourquoi cela peut vite devenir
très exigeant physiquement
c'est un sport que tout le monde peut
pratiquer sans forcément faire
d'exercice
mais à partir d'un certain niveau il
faut une vraie conditions sportives et
donc c'est vrai que crépy ping s'est
aussi montré que le tennis dé table on a
besoin de ces gens m'ont a besoin de ses
abdos et c'est pas seulement comme sur
la plage à bouger la raquette du joueur
professionnel vont te bouger la raquette
du 13 au 20 mai prochain paris lors des
championnats du monde